I do not feel as if my right machine is making
a positive difference in my healing process.
Are you able to update by frequencies?
Also, why is Monday not shown as an option
in the daily settings?
Oh, good question.
Why Monday's not shown?
I don't.
No, the most common reason why a person loses a program
is because they accidentally would clicking on it
dragged it somewhere.
We've seen that, if we've seen that once,
we've seen it a hundred times.
It's really easy to do by accident.
You're accidentally dragging a program
and you don't realize it.
You go, where's my program?
Or you could drag the whole folder into another folder.
You could drag the program into another program.
You could drag it into another folder.
It's all sorts of different things.
But the Monday did not be there.
I, it's almost impossible.
It's almost impossible for you to delete it.
You'd have to right click, hit delete
and then say, yes, I want to delete it.
So nobody does that.
So I'd have to look at that
and we might have to look at your program.
Yes, we could update your frequencies.
Absolutely.
We should do a cheek swab.
Make sure that you're not just doing the right.
Make sure you're doing the recommended nutrition
and supplements and diet along with it.
As always, we don't think the right is a magic one.
It's using, using frequencies to help heal you
and help stimulate the immune response.
But if you're not doing other things
to stimulate the immune response,
it's going to have less effects.
So we want to do as many things as we possibly can
dealing with as many facets of your health as you possibly can.
So answer to that.
We should probably do another cheek swab
and make sure we're at that right track.